how is morale on the TNT set Ernie has
never been higher believe me there is
allowed men okay but I can't I can't
I'm so I'm so amused at the at the
response to that thing on social media
because I'm busy I'm traveling yesterday
and I'm looking at Twitter and I'm
seeing people responding to this thing
and I'm like and have you not been
watching the show I mean I've heard that
exact same exchange ah 50 times this
year so it's going to be some furniture
moved around here well if you weren't so
fat well if you didn't need so much well
if you have any rings it's just like you
saw you saw I bailed on that whole
exchange I just started eating the food
they had brought out there it was I did
that his that's a tired
that's a tired back and forth there's
nothing there guys doing what they do
well it's like stepbrothers the movie
that they kind of love each other but
they go at each other in a fun way but
when you said I think flippin and
instead of something out like you were
you were tired of hearing it that a fair
light - well well it was it was Charles
was getting on me because because I was
eating so much food and I because I
really couldn't let those crab cakes go
you know really good and so so I'm
eating these things and he's like man
you got to eat that whole thing I said
well look I'm doing this because you
haven't here yet instead of little thing
that's been interesting
so I or any you haven't said anything
worth a flip is what I said yes because
if I had said flipping it would have
sounded like Napoleon dinamo flipping
business Stan gosh gosh do you know I
work at heels go on lucky your mother
took a spill Allah say your grandmother
took a spill on the sand dunes and
brokered cooks hunger that do whatever
they feel like gum
nice now you're getting into the whole
vibe that we have on our show in
commercial breaks when the production
truck and I go back and forth was not
only Napoleon Dynamite but with
naturally Bri we it feels like it's it's
a not hour to hour but it's night by
night that we assess LeBrons legacy and
and you know now you put an asterisk by
this and he's no Jordan because Jordan
would never have a game like we saw in
Game three well it it's pretty amazing
though that social media in how we
dissect now we went from Kyrie Irving to
oh yeah he's a really nice player too is
he the best wingman ever
and I went later chapter one game now
LeBron camera it is Jordan because of
Game three it's wearying yeah Dan it
really is I think we're always in such a
hurry to make everything an absolute
come on let you know let guys play out
their careers do we always have to put
somebody at this rung of the ladder
after every game ok now this guy's the
best there's now use the fifth best in
postseason history not let it let it
play out let's see exactly how it all
how it all plays out that that does get
wearying for me where it's like oh now
where does he rank well after Game three
he was my fourth best player of all time
but now I three scored 21 in the third
quarter he must beat it just let him
play enjoy the games and lets you know
and let's see if we do get the finals
that everybody lost I think we will I
don't know if that's going to happen
tonight or if it's going to happen after
Game six but yeah I mean there's just
there's so much hand-wringing and oh my
goodness after after every game of the
playoffs you know I think ultimately
when you look back on 2017 10 and and I
think you know I've heard a lot of folks
say man these playoffs look at all the
blowouts 44 games on 73 and always look
when you look back on the year 2017
they're gonna and somebody wasn't around
then hey grandpa tell me about the
season 2017 looks like it must have been
a heck of the year because you had a guy
average triple-double for the first time
since Oscar and and you had the two
finalists meeting for the third straight
time and they'd only lost one game
between us before the fight yeah I mean
that's how the season will be remembered
it won't be remembered because boy can
you believe that you know it took San
Antonio six games to beat Memphis that's
right tyronn lue had some comments about
Boston is tougher to defend than the
Golden State Warriors yeah yeah it's
just a topic tonight with the boys
yeah of course it will be you know but
it'll you know what but I say it'll be a
topic but it doesn't mean it's going to
be a great topic it's like it's like
it's like the other night Charles
opinion the other night was yeah I know
we're going to talk about LeBron but I
think it's the most overblown story out
there but sure we'll address it but you
know look I see what time which I knew
was saying it I think if the heck do
over he would take out the Golden State
reference and just talk about Boston
being a tough game to defend when there
when the when the guy who's who's so
bald um and it is not in there you know
now what are they going to do it so it's
tougher to prepare for a team like that
when when when you know what what it is
they like to do what Isaiah Thomas but
yeah so I think his his his mistake is
invoking the name of the Golden State
Warriors and saying they're you know the
Celtics are tougher to defend and oh
that's going to go up on the bulletin
board and all this stuff so yeah we'll
talk about it but I I don't think the
reaction will be like oh yeah he's now
there's no way Cleveland will ever beat
Golden State because tyloo ticked them
off he's Ernie Johnson jr. Turner Sports
host you can see Ernie and the boys
tonight exclusive coverage of the NBA
Eastern Conference Finals it's tonight
at 8:00 Eastern from Boston I have a
real list like at least I hope so
because because Shaq and Charles aren't
speaking I'm just kidding
if they had a fist fight or any who do
you have your money on oh [ __ ] well you
know what that punch had connected by
Shaq back when they were playing yeah
remember we've shown that footage
forever then this show would have never
happened we never would have had that
Charles would have been
I mean that was that was what about at
estimating offend in his life I mean
that's that punch so I saw shot the
other day picked Charles up after the
show when we were walking out he just
came up behind him and lifted him up he
lifted Charles off before his feet were
three feet off the floor so I guess I
would take check he's he's just his
strength is ridiculous and so and I'm
not it see this is the theory they're
not going they're not they're not going
to they're not known it okay both of
them are smart enough to not do that and
and there has to be for me to have a
fist fight take place dan and I have not
had up this fight in a long time I would
say that but there has to be animosity
and there is none here so there's not
going to be a fist place wait you were
involved in at this point a long time
ago this is just going back when you're
growing up there in fact my dad had told
me I mean what a source is ridiculous
I'm like an eighth grade and got pickup
basketball games have been getting kind
of rough and I told my dad about one
night when I came home and he said why
are you taking that from that guy I said
well he's bigger than I am
he said well you can't take that so the
next day the guy followed me and I
pushed in and he hit me right below the
left eye and I saw stars and I was like
okay that was worth it did you tell your
dad yeah yeah what you didn't even we
saw the black SL the shiner is a he will
play basketball again but I said yeah I
took a swing on this guy and he any deck
mate I said they said well that's what
you got to do yeah you taught Emma
listen I'm in love your daughter
i'ma leave you with this I have a real
problem with the all-nba teams that you
have two forwards two guards in a center
because Paul George and Gordon Hayward
you know lost some money because of this
I'm assuming one of the two would have
been on the top three teams there I
don't like the fact that the media is
deciding this on what happens with these
players in these teams you can't tell me
that Rudy Gobert is one of the top ten
players
the game I think if you're going to do
it you have to do the five best players
the next five and then the next five and
now I'm not do by position your thoughts
earning not I mean that's a certainly
something to consider you know what I
want I have to fill these things out to
it's like sometimes I would rather do
that - I would rather kind of like here
I'll give you my my top 15 players but
then there but that's not a key you know
a team there's two guards two forwards
in the center but my question also is if
we're going to do all stars by three
frontcourt into backcourt then why don't
we do all NBA by tree frontcourt
- backcourt because because now you have
to pick us up so yeah I'm with you on
that I think I see that those things can
be could be altered somewhat but it's
finished
and you have about I used to when I
worked at the mother yeah and because
you know it's a there are certain things
when you're filling that out that are
like man I don't know well who is second
team all-defensive let's see
and who is second team all-rookie like
second team all-rookie this year is very
difficult yes
Janna and my time of the first team
all-rookie okay no kidding it's
worthless and so when you do all NBA
again that's you know I think it's kind
of so it's kind of silly to me that that
we do our all-star voting one way and
then we do all in ba yeah when you have
to have a center yeah so I'm with you
hey what you doing he's the mother
Teresa of Turner Sports C's Ernie
Johnson camping the piece tonight the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience